jetzt ist das album raus von mo trip und
es hat schon eine menge
vorschusslorbeeren bekommen denn mode
chip ist ein ausnahme rapper das ist
nämlich der mann mit
migrationshintergrund der seine lehrer
korrigiert hat und anderen schülern
geholfen hat also des deutschen nicht
nur mächtig sondern er kann damit
virtuos umgehen und es ist auch in
anderer hinsicht eine ausnahme rapper er
sagt nämlich andere rapper zeigen nicht
ihr herz was er damit meint und mit
allem anderen das erfahrt ihr jetzt im
interview und wenn er nichts verpassen
wollt genau abonnieren nicht vergessen
bis dahin bleibt was geht ab hier
klickst du modische zum interview auf
deinen lieblings youtube-kanal clixoom
gibt dir
aufgelöst ja ich habe damit gerechnet
die lage ist senkrecht aufsteigend und
aufrecht woran liegt das ist eine
positive aufbruchstimmung hier bei mir
allgemein im ganzen team bei allen die
man mir zu tun haben wir bringen ein
album gerade raus wir fühlen uns gut wir
stehen dahinter videos gedreht da fühlt
man sich schon eine senkrecht lage okay
aber
dass ich sag mal wenn man jetzt liest
wie lange schon texte schreibt und wie
schnell das jetzt hier aufwärts gegen
der letzten zeit dann hat sich da was
massiv verändert unfairer ja sieben
jahren müsste weckt werden ja und dann
ja aber das heißt nicht dann wäre das
sind ja nicht ich habe ja immer schon
ein bisschen resonanz bekommen und ich
weiß nie ganz und entdeckt aber erst
recht im letzten jahr hat sich das alles
für multipliziert für multi fach noch
aber gezielt war das nicht oder mal dass
gezielt hast du gezielt darauf
hingearbeitet oder hat sich plötzlich
alles was nicht wirklich wenn ich
gewusst hätte wie hätte ich ja schon
vorher versucht so wenn man das so gibt
es hier jetzt vor fünf jahren zumal
diese weise verfügen damenrad aktion
musik machen und so ein geld damit
verdienen aber dass ist so echt eine
anreihung von positiven zufall
hingewiesen ohne wird es also bewusst
immerhin so sachen rein die einfach
unfassbar positiv sind das fing mit
meinem management an der wo ich dann in
cover my song gerutscht bin
wonach die aufmerksamkeit dann glaube
ich
multipliziert wieder wurde so also ich
glaub cover my song ist ein großer punkt
aber da kam ich auch nicht von alleine
oder sonders über das management der und
den guten kontakten noch irgendwie als
beim auto sowie da gibt es einen
unbekannten rappern kennt keine sau aber
der könnte der verfahren sind auch bei
sollen ansonsten waren favorite drin wir
waren noch alles drin selbst soccer cage
so also keine leute die man schon er
kennt das licht ja ja das ist
reingekommen ja also könnte man jetzt
zusammenfassen hey du brauchst du das
richtige management dann geht's los die
box kamen natürlich gucken wer ist da
ist ja ich werde vorschlagen und wenn
ich jetzt nicht positiv auf die also
dann ist das gut angekommen wir hätten
die mich einfach gar nicht genau aber
die karmann haben sich das ersten probe
gedreht hatten sofort du bist die erste
folge und da hat sich noch 0 erfahrungen
im märz 2006 geschafft und jetzt im
nachhinein sogar meine folge zum
grundpreis familie aber stolz woran
liegt das also noch mal wieder die dumme
frage was kannst du was andere nicht
können um es mal platt aus und musste
ganz platt sondern texte schreiben ja
also rappen können viele so ich finde
sogar ich habe leute schon texte
geschrieben wo ist mehr mochte die auf
ihre motoren also ich sag nicht ich bin
da aber genau das ist ja ich bin fürs
texte schreiben globus bekannt und das
kannst du warum so gut das weiß ich
nicht mein onkel mein vater schreiben
unheimlich gute gedichte das habe ich
erst vor zwei drei jahren erfahren
wirklich das hat meine ganze kindheit
ist bewusst ist bobs geerbt nebenbei hat
mein bruder mir das beigebracht ist höre
so keine ahnung ist höher guten rap
sodann du sammelst du lernst ja auch von
den anderen die gar keine ahnung okay
aber dein bruder hat keinen vertrag beim
major-label im gegensatz zu dir noch
nicht noch nicht noch aber trotzdem ist
jünger als er ja ich bin immer das heißt
es hat schon was
irgendwie unglücksfall zu tun oder wird
zu sagen du kannst besser als sein
bruder soweit ich weiß haben leicht
reden auf einem level so es aber ich
habe alles von ihm gelernt ich habe viel
von ihm gelernt und er im nachhinein
auch von mir zurück also wie das ist ein
geben und nehmen aber mein bruder hat
ist nicht so hartnäckig losgezogen ist
mein bruder hat einfach eine tochter
bekommt leben in den griff kriegen
mussten arbeit so er hat das erstmal auf
eis gelegt und dadurch dass ich jetzt
wieder sage ich mal so durch start fängt
feuer was ich gut finde wir sind wieder
voll im team arbeiten aber das war nicht
der grund ich glaube in hausham von
anfang an dass auch los gezogen hat hat
er auch dass auch von alleine das heißt
ja so und du hast das nicht gewusst wird
dein vater dass er warum hat er dann
nicht wenn sowieso nicht also das
schreibt die für sich hat dann so eine
tasche mit ein paar zettel wir hatten
jetzt im nachhinein mal gezeigt dass
meistens auch auf arabisch also er macht
es ganz selten auf deutsch aber dann
sage ich mir es ist
unfassbar schöne wörter informationen
gefühl dafür mit worten umzugehen und
keine ahnung er schreibt dann über
frieden nachteile und du hast das gefühl
alles gesagt was gesagt werden kann und
das reimt sich dann noch im bestfall und
was mich erstaunt die haben wirklich so
die haben später aldi am floß wirklich
an verschiedenen techniken und mein
onkel wollte lieber und lebt dort noch
und es war jetzt gerade vom fahrrad
sagen da unten und er hat etwas
vorgelesen was er geschrieben hat
unfassbar wirklich habe gänsehaut
bekommen ich gesagt das hat noch nie
einer geschafft mit acht sein die mir
sagt so 'ne gänsehaut zu verpassen und
ich glaube ich hab's teilweise geerbt
ohne wird wenn du dass du merkst also
wenn du jetzt so in dem alter merck stay
da sind meine wurzeln
was ist das für ein gefühl merkt man
lebt dann vater und sein onkel deine
familie quasi in der auf- oder sehr
schön also ich hoffe dass die das gefühl
haben dann ja schön cool das
repräsentiert und sowie leben darin auf
aber das würde ich mal jetzt nicht weiß
ich nicht ob sie das tun aber ich habe
auf jeden fall nicht nur diese bezüge
von meinem vater so ich erkenne mich in
vielen sachen wieder und auch die
geschwister meines vaters sagen mir dass
du bist mein vater und ich glaube so das
macht man unbewusst man kriegt einfach
einiges mit und das macht das eher fürs
um hier seid stolz auf mich dass
schreibt jetzt auch es ist einfach so
aber es entstand auf dich ja jetzt ist
der staat lange ein problem damit gehabt
oder was heißt problem der plan nicht
verstanden was ich hier so überhaupt
mache
rappen ohne geld also man verdient nicht
wirklich kohle am anfang die erste ohne
ziel genauso einfach mal gesagt ihr
glaubt mir ich bin gut so ich kann war
es so dass kann nicht so viele und das
hat mir auch geblockt das ist nicht an
bord immer dass meine schule machte
nebenbei was soll gemacht habe und es
war vollkommen vernünftig und ich bin
ihm sehr dankbar dafür dass sie mich so
erzogen hat soll eine schule werde
durchgezogen und trotzdem mein ding
weiter gemacht und hätte mein vater
nicht so viel druck gemacht hat
wahrscheinlich die schule vorher
verlassen ist meine frau ist für schule
bisschen flogen oder gewechselt dann so
maßnahmen kam also ich hab viel gemacht
weil mein vater ist wollte und das
darauf bin ich stolz aber das richtig
sehe ich sehr sehr richtig und ich habe
es mit 23 jahren noch nicht als richtig
gesehen hab ich gesagt hey man kann
nicht beides und ich will nur musik
machen und ich wusste ja nicht was ich
anziehe land dass china heute mit der
sitze oder mein thema aber das wussten
wir alle nicht weswegen ich habe es
trotzdem daran geglaubt sagt nein man
muss eins machen und auch wenn es nicht
klappt dann kann ich immer noch dann
schule oder das studium hat mich dann
gebeten bitte macht zumindest seine
schule fährt ist gene studieren und
machte eine schule fertig das habe ich
gemacht und ich bin sehr stolz war sehr
richtig machst hast du dadurch gleicht
jetzt sogar ein besseres gefühl nach dem
motto da ist ein fundament unter mir
unter all dem was ich mache und ich habe
abitur also fachhochschulreife ich kann
wenn es mal nicht läuft oder auch wenn
es läuft ich kann studieren also lud
abriss gehört studiert oder hat so weißt
du das ist ludacris diskutiert oder hat
es ja kollegah studiert jura ist
natürlich zu gehen was könnte es immer
für welches fachgebiet hat bis heute
ohne wird es auch ich wollte immer
anderen werden als gelernter zumindest
das eingeredet früher manchmal
ausgebildet habe sehr gut okay aber es
wird erst etwas soziales machen okay so
ich habe jugendzentren so praktiker und
so im rahmen meiner amtszeit gemacht und
die haben es mir unheimlich beliebt wenn
nicht entkommen und mit den kids gegen
hält wache und ist das liegt mir folgen
wo ich glaube ich könnte etwas soziales
mit wurzeln nicht so streetworker jetzt
ganz klassisch aber schon so was also
anderen hält das team es ag das heißt
dass ich habe das auch in deiner auf der
auf dem album nicht gehört und nicht du
bist ein anderer rapper typ du bist eben
sozial engagiert die texte sind auch
etwas wo es eher darum geht um liebe
leben und so weiter und so fort aber im
positiven sinne
ich glaube zum gewalt oder doch einmal
haus glaube ich einmal eine rein oder
aber wenn dann ist bei mir nur sodann
aus einem neuen buch ins gesicht ok
facebook nur für den spruch okay so habe
aber nicht so weil ich jetzt aggressiv
bin oder ich bin ja sogar so ich
streiche schon manche textpassagen die
dann zum rest des albums nicht mehr
gepasst haben zu hart aber ich finde
dass ist genau ich das genau mein ding
ich hoffe das wird auch so angenommen
aber ich finde damit voll wohl und das
ist halt schon sagen das bin ich wenn
ich sage hier ist wird gern lassen das
machen um denen zu helfen dafür stelle
ich mich nicht wenn ich sage ich bin der
erste stern hat genug grips dann mache
ich das nicht weil ich denke die anderen
alle dumm muss und er hasst er stößt
aber ich bin der erste der dazu besteht
und die anderen eher verstecken das
extra sogar ihr gutes herz so da bist du
eher sehr cookson der asoziale zwang er
da bist du lieber anstatt so ein
normaler cooler helfender typ so dass es
da aus dem web problem und nicht getan
hast du werden dann eben nicht in der
rapperszene ein problem weil du bist so
nett und so liebt das kann doch kein
richtiger rapper war das also erst
natürlich ist aber trotzdem du siehst
und
doch es gibt natürlich leute also viele
verwechseln denn ehrlichkeit mit special
das wirklich auch auf meinem album und
es ist einfach scheiße also ich bin kein
schwächling oder floaters nett bin ich
kann mich mit jeden boxen den box thule
wenn es sein muss ich mal selber nicht
gern das warum hast du aber also ich
drücke mich davor keiner beantworten wir
sagen ja ich bin cool ich bin nett ich
bin einfach so mein vater gezogen gott
sei dank
mutter und ich bin stolz darauf wenn du
sagst das fällt mir auf dass seine texte
anders sind und du bist irgendwie nett
oder gut im vergleich zum bösen dann
habe ich mein ziel erreicht ok
sprache beherrscht die deutsche sprache
wird muss man doch es so sonst könnte es
ja nicht machen
ist das nicht ein komisches gefühl auch
in den klassen gewesen wahrscheinlich im
oder wie war das in deutsch ich habe
wirklich paar deutsche schüler
korrigiert weil ich jetzt nicht nur
klugscheißer aber ich wusste schon immer
das richtige wort wenn es ein nein es
musste oder wusste sogar drei
alternative wird dafür für den lehrer
wenn er gerade den satz nicht mehr
vollenden können sie wird willst also
ich spreche halt deutsche dem ich klein
bin ich mit einem jahr und acht monaten
hergekommen
aber wieder an was habt ihr denn in der
familie geredet habe doch wahrscheinlich
ein geschwister
und mein geschwistern solche mein held
haben bis heute ist deswegen kann ich ja
auch arabische banner ich hab es aber
irgendwie arabisch habe ich gelernt
deutsch war meine natürliche sprache die
sich aber die haare sind wie haben deine
eltern gekriegt die kann ja auch durch
die aber trotzdem es gibt ja viele
beispielsweise türkische familien wo
soviel türkisch gesprochen wird das hat
die kinder ich komme wenn sie die schule
können nicht genug deutsch können um
mitzukommen aber bei dieses ist ja
offensichtlich anders herum gewesen ich
habe jetzt mein vater schon zwei mal
genug loben ihn noch einmal mein vater
hat von anfang an gewollt dass wir nicht
nicht akzeptiert werden sondern dass wir
irgendwie schnell in die gesellschaft
aufgenommen werden und der erste weg
dahin ist lernt die sprache dann kannst
du arbeiten schule dann kannst alles
machen und mein vater wollte zwar immer
hat mich ab 10 auf zwischen schule
geschickt also wollte damals richtig
arabisch lernen aber viel wichtiger war
dass deutsch kann erstmal und ich war
der jüngste als wer kam mein älterer
bruder war also schon arabische schule
er kam als araber her konnte gar kein
deutsch lernen ich bin hier aufgewachsen
konnte se und erfahrt haben zum
nachhinein erst dazu über arabisch auch
und zehn sehr wichtig also er wollte
immer dass wir beten religiös den
arabisch lernen zur moschee gehen und so
eine sache habe ich auch eine zeit lang
durchgezogen so weit dass gegen
gespräche habisch aber deutsch ist
irgendwo also ich denke deutsch ich
träume in deutschland nämlich so wenn
ich in libanon bin fragt mich meine
familie super wir sehen was du machst
aber warum nicht englisch da können wir
das internet kann man das hier auch sagt
ey das ist die sprache der denke ich
kann ein bisschen englisch oder deutsch
versuche ein englischer texte zu
schreiben oder arabisch schlecht der
englische weiß wer da gibt es dann wir
sollten jetzt versuchen gegen ihn zu
unternehmen dann macht sie waren deutsch
oder gibt es nicht so viele dieser ist
so beherrschen findet und oder nicht mal
ist feier auch viele rapper aber hier
kann ich mich mit messen und das ist
mein ding so und ist nun stolz auf mein
vater dass er so durchgezogen
stehen jetzt die türen offen
ja offenbar als vorher hast du das
gefühl weil aber was ist das jetzt vom
moment also wirklich wie
was nicht wie fühlst du dich ist
eigentlich die falsche frage sondern
wenn du jetzt so das was wir bisher
erlebt hast und dann weißt du was noch
kommt als perspektive siehst was ist das
jetzt im moment also ist für mich
tatsächlich der moment ist der moment
bis angekommen sein so ich bin jetzt
angekommen aber wir haben noch gar
nichts erreicht das muss ich auch immer
wieder mal ganz klar sein ich habe
meinen will darauf nicht super stolz zu
es gibt nicht viele künstler die vor
ihrem ersten album the universe
unterschreiben so gibt es aber deswegen
also es gab auch gute kandidaten blog ja
aber es ist noch nichts erreicht das
kann nicht das album in die wand fahren
und dann tolle hat schon haben hier mal
haben wir schon mal sagen ich habe es
eben als einiger wenigen vorher hören
dürfen und das wirst du nicht gegen die
wand gefahren also wenn jemand der wie
ich nur sehr geringen grad so web hat
sagt hey das ist ein heim und das
wirklich mehr kaufen dann ist es etwas
was die leute erreicht sein könnte das
volk nicht wirklich also das ist mein
ziel so ich will nicht das ist für das
alle rapper dahinter stehen können
wirklich rapper eine stelle das andere
besonders krass dass alle web fans
dahinter stehen können und dass auch
alle anderen sich das anhören können das
war mein stil mit alle anderen meinte
zum beispiel wenn du sagst ich habe
einen grossen rat und das heißt es
trotzdem dann habe ich auch wieder mal
ein ziel erreicht aber um darauf
zurückzukommen ich fühle mich im moment
so sw esch angekommen als kann ich jetzt
loslegen ich habe jahrelang in die luft
gearbeitet wusste nie wo landet das was
ich werde jetzt sehe ich das ziel ist
muss man auch treffen weist in
malawi super körperkraft und das ist
eine rein gehabt jetzt steht der
dreierlinie aber ich habe noch nicht
getroffen er hat also nicht mal geworfen
aber den ball ganz richtig fest ich kann
doch also da ist anscheinend an meiner
hand keiner kann mir den ball mehr
wegnehmen außer ist der mann ist lobo
und du wirst und am zweiten märz dann
fängst an zu fliegen aber du musst
kannst du so wenn er ohne ribery oder
gar nicht also etwas ist auch immer
meinen segen ganz organisch deswegen gab
es um den release es war nie zufrieden
so ich wollte nicht so ein hinweis der
dann abtreibt und dann irgendwie bei
umwege da reingeht das ist mir da kann
ich nicht verstehen ich stehe richtig
hinter meinem album ich freue mich
richtig wenn du es sagst und cool ist ja
ein ziel erreicht ok dann hoffe ich dass
die weiteren ziele noch erreichen
tipp ein netter typ mehr von ihm zum
beispiel in roth unterwegs mit ihm in
aachen unten ähnlich entspannter rapper
das war fahrt im interview der unter
anderem über eine autogrammstunde
erzählt war der die polizei eingreifen
musste
das etap ort auf das sternchen klicken
interview mit fahrt zu diesem thema und
ansonsten stay tuned bis dann bleibt